si je vous dis bibimba si je vous dis
que les nouveaux mots du dictionnaire
sont sortis si je vous dis qu'ils nous
font les mêmes lancements depuis le noir
et blanc vous me croyez si je vous dis
si je vous dis qu'il y a pas de violence
et que vous pourrez chier cet après-midi
parmi les 150 nouveaux mots du Petit
Larousse l'écologie à la part belle avec
ses modes de vie parfois originaux
je connais pas c'est vouloir faire la
révolution du vélo
ça existe et oui de même que la
boboïsation boboïsé ce qu'on a un petit
bobo non c'est l'arrivée massive de Bobo
dans un quartier ça y est vous êtes en
place ça y est tout est tout est
centrées à équidistance les unes des
autres j'ai besoin j'ai des défauts
vous mettez évidemment en garde contre
tous les régimes miracles ça marche pas
et notamment
les régimes hyper protéinés on les
connaît mais celui-là en particulier
œuvre jambon poulet à donf
ça se voit
un mot peut-être que vous connaissez
quoi couper
alors rassurez-vous rassurez-vous sinon
le dictionnaire c'est pas rentrer dans
le dictionnaire mais moi je trouve que
c'est le mot de l'année je comprends pas
pourquoi je l'ai entendu mais je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire
pls
ce que ce qui vient de faire ou ce qui
vient de dire ça me met en PLS ça vous
arrive souvent oui ça m'arrive
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire gosser
[Rires]
je me fais planter la
Salima depuis tout à l'heure depuis le
début de l'émission pour donner mon avis
j'ai pas la parole si je la prends et
que vous foutez de ma tronche
et son entretien la semaine prochaine
vous inquiétez pas regardez là regarde
la faites un plan sur elle
regardez-la bien vous risquez de ne plus
la voir
c'est quoi c'est la règle et puis on a
des jolis anglicismes cette année le
flex office le le télétravail travaille
bureau nomade le greenwashing ça on
connaît pour une entreprise on va dire
de verdir son image et puis le Home
stagings opérations de mise en valeur
d'un bien immobilier dans le but dans
faciliter la vente personne suivante
chez Marie on garde son sérieux en toute
circonstance
on est obligé
[Musique]
adjectif pour qualifier ce qui suscite
la gêne je peux très bien dire que nous
en avons ras le bol de ce bidule nous
sommes trop transbahutés et préférons
être clodo kenarque si je vous dis que
le nouveau Larousse est sorti oui il y a
aussi le mot Nasser qui est rentré dans
le dictionnaire alors ça je l'ai pas
mais
je pense que c'est en rapport avec les
manifestations exactement
c'est l'action d'encerclée de retenir
des manifestants donc voilà on est
vraiment là dans l'actu dans la culture
il y a aussi l'antisexisme qui est
rentré quand tu as du mal à t'affirmer
féministe que ça te gêne d'avoir cette
étiquette tu peux au moins dire en tout
cas je suis antisexiste je suis contre
les violences sexistes
des personnes donc c'est un mot qui sert
à rien c'est vrai que les femmes entre
sont souvent cruels mais bon j'invente
rien on l'a déjà remarqué parce que on
est plus attentif parce que les signes
de vieillissement
se remarquent peut-être plus chez une
femme regardez comme il est beau avec
avec la barbe blanche encore
[Rires]
deux étudiantes ont imaginé une appli de
covoiturage réservée aux femmes alors
c'est comme blablacar mais là comme
c'est 100% féminin ça s'appellera bla
bla bla bla
[Rires]
apparition des termes liés aux nouvelles
technologies comme le metaves univers
virtuel tridimensionnel des mots liés
aux évolutions actuelles dans la vraie
vie si un comme drague toute les nanas
c'est un Charo ou un shlag
[Musique]
non
un Charo c'est un diminution de
charognard
crime et on aurait dit un lion qui est
de JC dans la savane quoi je crois que
tout le camping l'a entendu
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça fait mal on dirait un paillasson
de toute façon si je vous dis ça et que
vous avez un compte facebook c'est trop
tard vous êtes un boomer est-ce que vous
saviez que le patron de Facebook faisait
du ju-jitsu Mark Zuckerberg absolument
la prenez compétition cette art martial
ce week-end il a remporté même la
médaille d'or il s'en est en orgueille
on va dire sur le réseau social Facebook
année difficile pour son groupe l'an
dernier alors Mark Zuckerberg disait
qu'il s'était mis à ce sport pour
affronter les difficultés au travail
résultat un peu difficile pour le groupe
l'an dernier le résultat sont meilleurs
en 2023 peut-être grâce au ju-jitsu et
grâce au licenciement aussi donc
Facebook a viré 11000 personnes en
novembre et 10000 en mars vous aimez le
sucre
et ben
problème
c'est bien on est en direct on va les
couper mais non mais le sucre le sucre
des calories il y a des calories dans
l'alcool mais c'est pas grave c'est bien
d'avoir révélé ça au grand public parce
que je pense que les gens vous aiment
bien ils savent qu'ils ont aussi
quelqu'un qui est un peu cher